Speaker 1: Today, we're going to be speaking
with Christopher Key.
Christopher Key is a political activist, a
former fitness professional, and also the
leader of a group called the Vaccine Police.
Christopher, maybe you may recognize in my
audience may recognize Christopher because
he has been in the news over the last year
or two for both drinking and injecting urine
for reasons that he will certainly tell us
about.
Christopher, I appreciate your time.
Welcome.
Speaker 3: Oh, brother.
My tie just fell off.
Speaker 1: Well, I think we'll be able to
persevere.
Christopher, let me mention just so our.
Speaker 3: Audience, I fear.
No, man.
I fear not saying, Let's do it, brother.
Go ahead.
Speaker 1: I will let our audience know.
I believe you're either recording or streaming
our interview on your end because you are.
You don't trust that will run the interview
as recorded, is that correct?
That's what you told me before we started.
Speaker 3: That is completely correct, brother.
I trust no, no one in the mainstream at all.
You guys are prostitutes and talking parrots,
but go ahead.
Speaker 1: Good.
So since we're both recording it, we'll have
total clarity as to what's said.
So let's start.
When did you begin to drink urine?
And do you drink only your own urine?
Or do you drink other people's as well?
Speaker 3: I drink my own urine, brother.
And again, I did.
I started this nearly 24 years ago.
I heard a medical doctor talk about this and
I'm like that guys are crazy.
Not.
And then I heard.
David.
Avocado.
Wolf.
Speaker 1: Avocado.
Speaker 3: David Avocado.
Wolf is a good friend of mine.
And I heard him talk about and David's a little
out there, but I trust the man.
And then I heard a third medical doctor talk
about it.
And I, I, I like everybody.
I believes that you should trust your Lord
and Savior and test and prove all things,
brother.
Not some things, but all things.
And I'm like, really, Lord, I got to really
test and prove Pierce And I began to do the
research and I got the book, Your Own Perfect
Medicine by Martha Christie.
And I read through that book and I'm like,
Oh my goodness, brother, this could be real.
And again, this is liquid gold.
And what you don't understand.
Speaker 1: David Well, hold on, Christopher.
I'm I apologize for interrupting already.
We have about 15 or 20 minutes.
And I you know, I want to learn by asking
you questions, but it has to be a back and
forth.
So I was just asking how long you had been
drinking your own urine and whether it's yours
or other people's.
I think you answered that.
So let me I will mention to my audience two
of the folks that Christopher mentioned, David
Walt, David Avocado Wolf and Martha Christie
are both known medical disinformation purveyors.
You can look them up.
Christopher and I will disagree about that.
And that's okay.
Christopher I just am being clear with my
audience.
Is that okay?
Speaker 3: Completely understood.
Speaker 1: Okay.
But second question, your question.
Speaker 3: It was 24 years off and on for
24 years.
Yes, it's my own year and I don't drink anybody
else's urine.
Speaker 1: Okay.
What conditions do you believe drinking your
urine may cure or prevent?
Speaker 3: Again, brother, I'm not a medical
doctor.
I would never practice medicine about license
again.
I tell everybody, don't believe nothing I
tell you.
But do what the law commands each and every
one of us to do.
And that.
Speaker 1: No, but my question just what is
your.
But believe me, Christopher, everybody who
watches this knows you're not a medical doctor,
so don't worry about that.
I'm just saying, what do you believe the urine
does for you?
Speaker 3: Okay, well, let let me go in real
quick to help you understand.
There's you understand as a layperson that
any poison that comes into your temple, your
temple instantaneously creates antibodies.
Yes or no?
Speaker 1: My temple.
Like the temple in my head.
What do you.
Speaker 3: Mean?
You're you're I call the temple your body,
because that's what God calls.
It's the body.
So do you understand any poison that comes
into the body, your body easily creates antibodies.
Speaker 1: That is not my understanding of
the medical science.
But.
But neither one of us are doctors, right?
Correct.
Okay, good.
So I'm asking, what is it you're treating
or preventing with the urine?
Speaker 3: I don't try to prevent anything,
brother.
I drink it myself because I know it's the
perfect photonic memory of when the cells
were healthy.
Okay.
Because I know through medical science, any
poison that comes to this temple instantly
the crypt, the temple creates antibodies,
your liver spins it and you put it out.
And I believe all you have to do is take you
back.
Yeah.
And let me give you an analogy real quick.
If you were to get bitten by King Cobra, you
would take anti-venom, correct?
Speaker 1: I would.
I don't know.
It's never happened.
I don't know what I would do in a snake bite.
I'd call my doctor.
Speaker 3: Okay.
Call your doctor and your doctor would give
you anti-venom.
Do you know how to create anti-venom, David?
Speaker 1: You know, I don't I just don't
know if it's relevant to why you take your.
Speaker 3: It's very, very rare, okay?
Because the way they create, it's very rare.
And the way they create anti-venom is they
take a snake, whichever snake it is, a king
cobra, for instance, they milk it, they get
that venom.
They been injected into a horse or sheep.
Okay.
They can inject in any animal or any person
because instantaneously that animal will create
the antibodies is now in their blood.
So they then reinject the horse.
Sheep pull out the blood because the blood
now has the antibodies, they spin it and that
is how anti-venom is created.
Speaker 1: David Okay, but Christopher is
can, can we is there an answer to the question,
what do you believe drinking urine does for
you?
Speaker 3: Beautiful.
I believe anybody that's taken the bio bioweapon
are going to be dead in 2 to 5 years.
And I believe the antidote for those that
have taken the bioweapon.
Speaker 1: What is the bioweapon?
Speaker 3: The bioweapon is what they call
COVID 19 vaccine.
It's not it's not a vaccine.
It's a bioweapon.
Speaker 1: Okay.
But Christopher, before we get to that, before
we get to that and of course, many people
received their first vaccine years ago and
they're fine.
So I don't know if you'll eventually extend
it to 5 to 7 years or 7 to 9.
But Christopher, I want to wait a second.
Yeah, you've been you've been Drake drinking
the urine 24 years.
The COVID vaccines have only been around a
couple of years prior to the COVID vaccines.
What did the urine do for you?
Now you're saying it protects you from the
COVID vaccine.
But before the COVID vaccine, what did the
urine do for you?
Speaker 3: Again, as I told you earlier, and
I don't remember if you understood or heard
that it's the perfect photonic memory of when
the cells were healthy.
So I believe any poison that comes in the
temple, the temple creates antibodies, the
liver spends it and you piss it out.
And I believe one of the best ways you can
do is take it back.
You're not to.
And it is billions and billions of stem cells.
Do you understand?
You've already drink your own your arm, David.
Do you understand that when you were in your
mother's womb, you drink your own urine?
Did you understand that or.
No?
Speaker 1: No, that's not my understanding
of mammalian gestation.
But Christopher, let me ask you let me ask
you a different question.
Is there any medical science that supports
any of what you're saying here?
Specific studies you can point to?
Speaker 3: Yeah.
I sent your co-producer a long list and anybody
out there would get the doctor.
I mean, the book, Your Own Perfect Medicine
by Martha Christie.
There is.
Speaker 1: That book's been widely debunked
as disinformation.
Let me ask the question a different way.
Is there.
I know you sent Pat a bunch of stuff, but
now we're this is the show, right?
The audience doesn't see what you sent.
Pat, can you cite a randomized controlled
study proving the efficacy of drinking urine?
Speaker 3: Again, I am dyslexic, I'm LDA,
I'm ADHD, I'm RD and Dumber.
And that's what's so sad.
If I can figure this out, David, why can't
you take the time to do your own research
and your audience do your own research and
understand that the temple that God created,
He created a perfectly.
You know what, Christopher?
Speaker 1: This is a show like it's not it's
not super interesting to be like, Hey, we're
doing a show.
But you refused to cite any of the evidence
and tell the audience to Google stuff.
What I'm asking is, can you cite a single
peer reviewed study that will tell us what
drinking urine will do versus a placebo?
Speaker 3: Again, I sent all the data to your
to your friend, your co-producer.
Yeah, I'm giving you those clinical studies.
And I mean, why can't you put them up on,
you know, for a click?
Again, I don't remember the actual site.
Speaker 1: The reason I can't put them up,
Christopher, is we didn't find in going through
your list anything that would meet the standard
of a randomized placebo controlled urine trial
that proves the efficacy of drinking urine
for any condition, preventing or treating.
If we if you had sent us something that met
that standard, it would be all over the screen
right now.
But you're saying you don't remember them,
but you've been doing this 24 years.
Speaker 3: Again, I told you, I'm dyslexic,
I'm healthy.
And for me to remember a specific study number.
No, I sent you the book.
And again, you're on Perfect Medicine by Marty
Christie that you're saying stay.
But why listen or smart enough to go do the
research, whether it's smart enough to understand
it or not.
There is.
Speaker 1: So we'll leave it at you.
Is it just so we can move on?
Is it fair to say you assert the existence
of such studies?
You're unable to name them here, but the audience
can Google it.
Is that a fair place to just pause on that
so we can move on?
Speaker 3: Your own perfect medicine man,
Martha Christie.
Yes.
Okay.
Speaker 1: You've moved on, it seems, from
only drinking the urine to also injecting
it.
Is that true?
Speaker 3: I have.
And again, I'm not a medical doctor and I
would never tell anybody inject there.
No, I know I have I have injected my own urine.
Correct.
Speaker 1: What was the reason?
Hold on a second.
Speaker 3: Go ahead.
Speaker 1: What was the reason to switch from
drinking to injecting again?
Speaker 3: I drink and I also inject.
I do both.
Okay.
Because many of your listeners understand
stem cell therapy, correct?
Speaker 1: Some of them may.
But I'm just wondering why you made the switch.
Speaker 3: Again, Because I believe urine
has billions and billions of stem cells, especially
if you age it.
Okay.
And instead of spending 25 to $50000 going
to Mexico or going to different countries
to get stem cell therapy.
I've got my own stem cells in my own urine.
So I chose, after doing the research to inject
it into my shoulders that I've had reconstructed.
Speaker 1: Is the goal when you inject to
get it into the muscle, into a vein, where
are you trying to inject it?
Speaker 3: Again.
You're trying to get me to practice medicine
without license and.
No, no, no.
Speaker 1: No, no, no.
I'm just asking what you do.
Speaker 3: I inject it into the muscle, but
I would never tell anybody else to do that.
Speaker 1: Believe me, no one's going to do
it based on you telling anything.
Anything on this show.
Okay, So you inject it into the muscle.
You talk about aging urine.
Now, this is something that's interesting
to me.
Do you ever I, I apologize for the, you know,
seemingly strange language, but do you ever
season or flavor the urine in any way?
Speaker 3: The aged urine can be very, very
strong.
So I have added stevia to it to make it a
little bit more palatable.
Speaker 1: Stevia, I would have to kind of
chalked you up to be more of like a manuka
honey type guy.
Speaker 3: And I like that also.
But I've chosen to use stevia.
Speaker 1: When you talk about the situation
with the COVID vaccine, which you've talked
about.
And then just to be clear, just so we're meeting
all of the guidelines of all of the platforms
that were on my views on the COVID vaccine
are very clear.
I believe that it is a safe vaccine.
I think the new ones are not.
Hold on a second.
Christopher, we each get time to talk.
I believe that the the newest vaccines are
not effective at preventing transmission,
but are effective at preventing death and
serious illness.
Just to put that on the record, Christopher.
Speaker 3: That again, I need to hear say
that one more time.
You believe what?
Speaker 1: Well, it's I believe all of the
data that I've looked at suggests that against
the newest variants, the Bivalent vaccine
is very good at reducing the chance of death
from COVID and not good at preventing infection.
Speaker 2: Okay.
Speaker 1: Okay.
As far as the COVID vaccine goes, you and
I don't know if you're familiar with Sherri
Tenpenny.
Does that name ring a bell to you?
Speaker 3: It does.
Speaker 1: Okay.
You and Sherry and others have been saying
that tons of people are going to be dead from
the vaccine imminently.
Speaker 3: 1001 over a.
Speaker 1: Let me just finish the question,
Christopher.
Speaker 3: On the playing field.
And you're not talking about that.
Speaker 1: Product, Christopher.
I have to be able to ask you, I'm being polite
and giving you time.
Let me just ask my question.
Every time that you and Sherry say this sort
of thing, the time frame is always just beyond
where we are with sometimes it's it's six
months from now and now it's been years and
everybody's fine and then it's 2 to 5 years,
etc..
Why do you think the timing for the mass vaccine
death always is just a little bit into the
future?
Speaker 3: It's not, brother.
Have you not seen what's going on with insurance
companies around the world?
I mean, they're showing you we're having death
here in America like we never had before.
Okay.
You understand that if you take this bioweapon,
the number one side effect is clots mark or
die.
This strokes, heart attacks and death is plain
and simple.
And you.
Speaker 1: Christopher.
Christopher, hold on a second.
That's misinformation.
That's misinformation is the number one side
effect.
Hold on a second.
Hold on a sec.
Let's be really clear.
The number one side effect is arm soreness.
The number two side effect is a flu like malaise.
The number three side effect is headache.
And the number four side effect is fever.
That's the truth.
Christopher, are you willing to admit that?
Speaker 3: Again, from the data that you're
looking at, those are some of the side effects,
but also blood clots, stroke, heart attack,
death and myocarditis are side effects.
Would you admit that yes or no?
Speaker 1: I would admit that there are some
people who have had myocarditis and pericarditis.
I don't believe any have died from it.
And of course, the odds of that are a fraction
of the odds of muscle soreness.
Is it fair to say, Christopher, that when
90 seconds ago you said the most common side
effect is clot?
Are you willing to admit that's not true,
that the number one side effect is muscle
soreness?
Speaker 3: Okay.
Muscle soreness would probably I will consent
to that.
That that's okay.
Speaker 1: Are you willing to concede that
fever is more common than myocarditis?
Speaker 3: That fever is more common than
myocarditis.
That is very possible.
Speaker 1: Are you willing to concede that
headache is more common than pericarditis?
Speaker 3: Again, you're talking about three
very simple things that can happen with anything.
So, yes.
Speaker 1: But, Christopher, you're the one
who asserted that those are the most common
side effects and now you're admitting that
they're not.
So that's a big admission from you, isn't
it?
Speaker 3: Again, I believe the the most things
that people need to understand.
Okay.
I get sore arm fever.
Those are all very, very possible.
But.
Blood clots, strokes, heart attacks, myocarditis
in death is very, very likely.
And again, if dying of COVID is less than
1% of 1% of 1%, and why you would take this
bioweapon that we know we were the experiment
they told you in the book.
Speaker 1: Christopher, do you see how it's
tough to take you seriously?
Right.
It's tough to take you seriously when you
with full and total confidence, say the most
common side effects of the bio weapon are
clot, heart attack, stroke, death, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah.
And then within 90 seconds, you're admitting,
Hey, you know what?
What you just said isn't true.
What David said is true.
Would you understand that It's hard to take
you seriously when you say inject you?
Speaker 3: Oh, I would not, Because, again,
you know, fever and muscle, calmness.
Speaker 1: Muscle, calmness.
Speaker 3: Again, I misspoke.
So.
Excuse me.
I apologize.
Okay.
I'm not as articulate as that's okay.
But I'll try.
I believe again, those are common side effects
for any and all shots that you get.
Okay.
So I'm telling about true things that can
cause death.
All right.
This is.
Speaker 1: All right.
I got you that.
This is your this is your view as a non doctor.
Okay.
Let me ask you this.
You have entered some locations, including
Whole Foods, including Wal-Marts, etc..
Yes.
What do you do?
When is it that you yell things at the pharmacy
staff?
Speaker 3: What do you do?
What I do, let me answer.
What I do is I go in and I give them 11 undeniable
facts regarding all vaccines, brother, Regarding
all vaccines.
And I put them on notice.
Okay?
And once they've been put on notice, if they
continue to inject this bioweapon into the
people, we can then hold them civilly and
criminally liable.
And it's very likely they will all be harmed
because there is going to be Nuremberg 2.0.
Brother, one of the things you need to understand
and hear me when I say that I've been part
of four national championships, three separate
groups.
Speaker 1: Nobody.
Christopher, we can't just steamroll this
stuff.
You've made it.
You've made a claim.
I want to understand it.
Who's going to be hung under what law?
Who?
Who gets hung here at Nuremberg?
Speaker 3: 2.0 is coming, David And those
people that blindly did not do the research
and understand what has happened and they
can to Lebanon.
Deniable Facts.
Do you understand, David?
In 2010, the U.S. Supreme Court ruled that
all vaccines are unavoidably unsafe and white
versus British.
Do you not understand that?
Speaker 1: I'm not familiar with that case.
No, But Christopher, I really.
Speaker 3: You let me tell you this, okay?
I know what I know because my greatest accomplishment
in life that it is I'm a father.
My twins were born with one of the most rare
diseases on the planet called Phenylketonuria,
otherwise known as PKU.
Well, they'll never eat protein, no milk,
no chicken, no cheese, no fish, no birthday
cake, no ice cream, nothing that has protein.
What they ever eat, if they do, it becomes
toxic.
Go straight to the brain.
It causes the most extreme mental retardation.
David And because of their rare disease, I
was forced like everybody else should do,
and test and prove all things.
When I asked my pediatrician 24 years ago,
Can you show me the study that this new schedule
safe?
And he said, sure, Christopher, they're everywhere.
And I said, Can I see it?
And he said, Right now.
And I said, You're damn right, right now you're
about to inject my children.
He said, Nobody's ever asked me that, but
I'll have it for you by your next appointment.
My next appointment?
David.
I went in.
Oh, boy.
And he would look at me and he says, Christopher,
there are no studies, but Christopher, they
have to be safe.
They've been.
Speaker 1: You know, Christopher.
Speaker 3: The AM.
Hey, why are you back like that?
Speaker 1: As we talked about before the interview,
you know, we had about 15 to 20 minutes today
and we're kind of coming to the end of that.
I think you actually just maybe told us the
most important thing in this entire thing.
And I actually am developing radical empathy
for you, Christopher, And I'm going to tell
you why.
You just mentioned something very interesting.
You said your kids have this rare condition.
Speaker 3: PHENYLKETONURIA Yes.
Or PKU.
Speaker 1: That is a condition that affects
many things, but it affects the urine significantly.
Yes.
I actually believe and I feel I feel empathy
for you for this.
I think it's possible you've become obsessed
with urine.
Because of this condition that your children
have, which makes the urine musty and mousy.
And I feel really bad about that.
Christopher.
I think that that's what's going on here.
Is that possible?
Speaker 3: No, brother.
It is what's possible here and probable is
I did what my Lord commands each and every
one of you to do, and that is test and prove
all things.
And when I began to look at the vaccines that
led me down, looking at the food, that's all
genetically modified, that led me to look
at what they're spraying in the sky.
That led me to look at the poison.
Your government, David.
They don't love you, brother.
They're not here to keep you safe.
And your listeners out there, you may think
I'm crazy, but anybody out there that's listening.
David, I challenge you these little paint
chips that you laugh about.
Anybody out there?
So many people are in pain right now, These
little chips, they work.
When we did the randomized double blind placebo
studies at my University of Alabama.
Speaker 1: Christopher, people don't even
know what you're talking about.
Christopher Just put a sticker on his forehead,
which he says cures pain.
Christopher Listen, let's have you back to
talk about the stickers because we're just
out of time.
I do.
I have feelings of radical empathy for what
is going on with you.
We've been speaking with Christopher Key.
He's a political activist, a former fitness
professional, the leader of the Vaccine police.
And Christopher, as I told you, we don't cut
these interviews up.
We're not going to take you out of context.
It will air as recorded.
And I really do appreciate your time today.
Speaker 3: Brother.
I so appreciate you allowing me to come on
and tell my part of my truth.
And anybody out there that's listening, My
phone number is 2059369803.
If you give me your name, address and email,
I will send these out for free.
Yeah.
Prove you that this is real, brother.
Speaker 1: All right, Christopher Key.
I appreciate your time, sir.
Speaker 3: Lady, don't forget about my dear
Anthony Vote, Brother.
The product was banned by the NFL, the PGA
Major League Baseball and the NCAA.
Because it works so well, brother.
Speaker 1: All right.
Thank you very much.